how's it going bros and welcome to
another episode of scotland ear for low
ready smash like on this video to accept
the challenge if you laugh you will lose
can you beat me the grand master that
the top elite of this challenge bring it
on if you're not a coward and smash like
right now and let's freakin do this wait
do they just kick him out of the game or
do they kill it what's the command
yeah it's slash kill this is literally
me when I die in video games which never
happens this is me when I try to shake
someone's hand but no one wants to I
wonder why that was okay freaking decent
intelligence I can make a lot of animal
noises I can make a baby bird damn
anyways I can also make a cat from the
second try I gotta what am I I can also
sound like a chihuahua
[Music]
no I'm just gonna have to use my no pass
from that one me
I named my cat after fortnight friend
you named him fortnight me no his name
is garbage no one plays fortnight
anymore since I played it okay get with
the times losers you still play
fortnight
Wow
this is Luke very nicely too bad we got
to change the audio oh well they
completely ruined everything
kids getting hurt will never not be
funny
last weekend kids will always be funny
especially if they're hurt what are they
doing did he just try and read it -
that's not funny
yeah it's rewind time beat the challenge
not saying the n-word tag holy [ __ ] okay
that wasn't a good idea
god damn Oh
goddamn bugs out of treatment - oh my
god yeah
[Music]
that's amazing native huge prize
tempting but i'ma go eat some poo forgot
my license
okay well I mean that's one way to do it
oh god I've seen they okay I actually
thought this was the surreal exercise
what struction - looks amazing
I'll definitely watch it I don't know
why that edit is so satisfying I've seen
it I'm seated pop up everywhere now we
have faith for you so good I love it oh
[Music]
god here we go
I have always loved you new meme format
life slightly miserable less miserable
Thank You memes thank you doesn't it
feel good you discover a new meme and
URL and you just realize hey look
everything is a little little better now
whatever you're going through at least
is a little less annoying each that and
then by that time like I've put off
everything else that's been dying
hello ninja I am just confirming your
order for 12 inch thick black dildo for
tomorrow at 9 a.m.
should i reschedule the order delivery
for another time complain about my
lighting what is they imagine if I shot
my videos like this oh my god it came
back but even better it's already
running a little dry
I don't know what to tell you yes wanna
hear my longest yeah
come on do it
I need help
I never explicitly said harmonii with
white Oh get better material Dumbledore
was gay grander boy Grindelwald was gay
research her pet that reminds me of that
tweet from that guy youtuber guy Fraser
no one JK Rowling Dobby has a 12 10 inch
[ __ ] shouldn't have said 12 clearly not
a good tweet try again alright so if
you're attracted to ariana grande she's
23 years old sure but she looks like a
12 year old child
look she's standing like a baby squirrel
baby baby Stan that's a baby Stan's
crazy Jake our Apple the fame came so
quickly and recently she wasn't used to
it and she struggled because she doesn't
like all the camera she's wants this
thing she isn't really strong Italian
family I need to see my Nana
oh yeah oh yeah okay hope you guys
enjoyed this video
whatever this dancing
to burst simulator it's now so relevant
that it's got a brand new minigame
crania drop the crane and get fresh
items only available in the washing
machine like game and you say there's
more of course there is new knowledge
perks new quests and new pics links and
legs guys legs
[Music]
[Applause]